[Music]
the first time ever that
actually boys in instinct have ever done
something together like this
nick the 13 year old in me is having her
mind
blown right now well lance and i have
been speaking for quite some time
so we just basically had this idea that
evolved
that said hey listen you know obviously
you know pride month is very important
why don't we just do something together
[Music]
we're set to perform a couple songs by
backstreet boys a couple songs my
instinct i think we're just gonna do the
the hits i want it that way and bye bye
bye
[Music]
what's your favorite in sing song is
there one you wish you'd recorded
yes i'm a big fan of uh i want you back
[Music]
e.t et's been right there with these two
boy bands as both became
legendary but was there ever some boy
band bad blood
chris kirkpatrick once confessed there
was a time when i couldn't be
in the same room with aj mclean how real
was that rivalry it kind of became real
because you know
in uh when you're out there and you're
you're competing it was
pushed a little bit from our managers
but uh in the end you know we're we're
all still here and now we're becoming
friends which is great
well turns out the two boy bands have
kinda performed together before
e.t was at the 2001 super bowl where
nsync did the halftime show
while the bsb sang the national anthem
[Music]
how was it felt like i was at home
put it that way for us we we got the
choice
and we passed on the halftime
but it was a but it was a memorable
experience you know for everyone and and
it was everyone was able to share
you